genau um 15 uhr beginnt diese debatte ab
12 uhr wird mit den ersten
demonstrationen
gerechnet was denken sie wir haben eine
repräsentative umfrage unter allen
deutschen mit unserem
meinungsforschungsinstitut insel gemacht
im flechte ja oder nein das sagt
deutschland schauen wir auf diese
spannende grafik hier ja sagen 58,5
prozent nein 35,1 und weiß nicht
6,4 also hier eine eindeutige mehrheit
dafür mit wie vielen dosen soll denn
geimpft werden das haben wir sie auch
gefragt mit einer dose ist das sind 3,3
mit 2 1 13,1 und den booster also die
auffrischimpfung da sind 61,2 prozent
dafür also hier ebenfalls eine ganz
klare mehrheit
ja und wie soll der staat diese
impfpflicht dann überhaupt durchsetzen
haben wir sie gefragt mit einem ins
register sagen 64 9% bußgelder 59,8
prozent polizeikontrollen 29% und andere
maßnahmen 6,6 weiß nicht hier vier
prozent und dann haben wir sie auch noch
gefragt ob sie denn glauben dass die
impfquote steigen wird wenn es eine
impfpflicht gibt da gibt es dann keine
eindeutige mehrheit mehr 39,6 prozent
glauben daran ja das ist etwas steigt
das sagen
36,9 prozent das ist natürlich
interessant impfpflicht aber keiner
glaubt daran dass die impfquote um die
es ja dann eigentlich wirklich geht
dadurch tatsächlich wirklich steigen
wird und auch hier wird sehr deutlich
gibt es bei impfpflicht weniger corona
tote wollten wir zuletzt von ihnen
wissen und da sagen ja
66,1 prozent nein 28,8 prozent weiß
nicht in diesem fall 5,1 prozent dass
also die meinung der deutschen ihre
meinung ob die impfpflicht kommt
entscheiden allerdings nicht sie in
einer volksbefragung etwa sondern das
tun die abgeordneten die volksvertreter
und dann schauen wir doch mal wie die
derzeit so ticken wie sie aufgestellt
sind um eine ahnung davon zu bekommen ob
es eine mehrheit für die impfpflicht
geben wird wer will da was bei der m
schlecht teilweise nimmt das jetzt mal
für uns für sie unter die lupe
thomas sonst antrag kommt auch mal mit
rein hier in den bundestag ich habe
schon mal aufgeschlossen hier ist das
plenum mit den weit über 700
abgeordneten und vor den meisten
abstimmung weiß man ja schon die einen
ticken so die anderen werden so
abstimmen und heute vor dieser ersten
debatte ist völlig unklar was hier im
parlament gedacht wird der spalt geht
quer durch die gesellschaft und der
spalt geht auch quer durch die
fraktionen der weit über 700
abgeordneten und quer durch die
regierungsbank da haben sich viele aber
auch nicht alle festgelegt von ihm
wissen was das haben wir gerade schon
gesehen olaf scholz der kanzler der hat
sich hierbei bild live ja festgelegt im
dezember und hat gesagt ja er ist jetzt
auch für eine impfpflicht von ihm wissen
wir dass auch von karl lauterbach der
hat auch mitgearbeitet an einem der
anträge in seinem gesundheitsministerium
also der befürwortet natürlich auch ganz
klar die impfpflicht bei ihr ist das
auch so annalena baerbock und bei ihm
dem vizekanzler robert habeck beide
haben sich zuletzt für die impfpflicht
ausgesprochen bei ihm ist das nicht so
klar christian lindner hat sich dazu
nicht klar positioniert in den
vergangenen tagen in den vergangenen
wochen auch marco buschmann hat
fragezeichen an eine allgemeine
impfpflicht für alle
gerichtet also das ist hochspannend auch
innerhalb des kabinetts ist diese
impfpflicht tatsächlich umstritten
bilden wir doch mal zwei mannschaften in
der regierung und im bundestag das team
dafür für die impfpflicht und das team
dagegen bin können wir da von den
prominenten spitzenpolitikern schon zu
ordnen habe ich gerade schon getan olaf
scholz natürlich der geht mal ganz
schnell in das grüne team dafür ebenso
karl lauterbach ebenso annalena baerbock
ebenso robert habeck volker wissing
gegen der verkehrsminister bisherige
fdp-generalsekretär hat sich eher auf
der anderen seite bisher positioniert
eher skeptisch den mache ich mal hier
ganz an den rand des teams dagegen
christian lindner hier in der mitte im
moment noch wir haben gleich als
studiogast konstant die coole von der
fdp vielleicht weiß er schon mehr was im
kopf von fdp chef christian lindner dem
bundesfinanz minister vor geht ganz
interessant dass die entspannen der
bisherige gesundheitsminister sich
ursprünglich auch immer gegen die
impfpflicht positioniert hatte und das
auch nach wie vor beibehält erhält diese
impfpflicht weiterhin für nicht sinnvoll
in diesem team dagegen ganz klar sahra
wagenknecht von der linken die komplette
fdp-fraktion und dann ein ganz
prominenter
fdp-politiker wolfgang kubicki er ist
heute ein ganz entscheidender kopf im
bundestag denn er führt einen der
anträge an die gegen die impfpflicht
stimmen werden also er führt sozusagen
den widerstand gegen diese impfpflicht
formal im bundestag an dirk wiese den
mann kennen sie möglicherweise noch
nicht den müssen sie sich aber auch
heute merken der ist nämlich ein
entscheidender mann im team dafür der
hat den antrag geschrieben für die
impfpflicht im bundestag und dann gibt
es unter diesen köpfen die diese anträge
gestellt hat einen dritten
entscheidenden und das ist auch ein fdp
mann der hat einen kompromiss sozusagen
eingebracht der möglicherweise ein ganz
heißes rennen machen könnte enkelmann
ist das arzt fdp mann und er führt
diesen antrag an für eine impfpflicht ab
50 das könnte möglicherweise der
kompromiss werden im bundestag um alle
wieder zusammenzuführen der
möglicherweise der erfolgversprechendste
es interessant auch konstant die kohle
unser gast gleich hier im studio
unterstützt genau diesen antrag weiter
mit euch thomas uns an tel
vielen dank dass also die aufstellung
für die emotionalste